[موسيقى]
مع بدايه العام الدراسي الجديد غدا في
ايران يبدا تطبيق قرار الحكومه بمنع
البنات في الجامعات من دراسه اكثر من 70
تخصصا خطوه اثارت انتقادات داخليه
[موسيقى]
وخارجيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل يمكن اعتبار القرار تمييزا في
التعليم ضد المراه يعكس رغبه حكوميه
لتحجيم دورها العام وكيف يمكن قراءه السعي
الايراني للتقدم خاصه في المجال النووي مع
صدور قرار بتضييق تعليم
الفتيات
منذ اليوم لم يعد بمقدور الفتيات في 36
جامعه ايرانيه من الالتحاق ب 77 تخصصا
منها الفيزياء النوويه والاقتصاد وبعض
فروع في الهندسه والادب الانجليزي وعلوم
الكمبيوتر القرار يثير جدلا في الساحه
الايرانيه بين مؤيد ومعارض حتى بين اساتذه
الجامعات بل ان البرلمان يرفض القرار
طالما ان الحكومه لم تطلعه عليه مسبقا اما
في الخارج فرات فيه المعارضه فرصه للهجوم
على النظام بدعوه التمييز ضد المراه كما
طالبت منظمه هيومان رايتس وتش في بيان لها
الحكومه الايرانيه بسحب
القرار عشرات الاختصاصات العلميه في
الجامعات الايرانيه باتت حكرا على الرجال
بمقتضى قرار حكومي اثار الكثير من الجدل
حوله القرار الذي نقل عن بعض المصادر
الحكوميه وصفه بالمؤقت يحرم النسوه
الايرانيات في 36 جامعه ايرانيه من
الالتحاق بشعب من قبيل الفيزياء النوويه
والهندسه وعلوم الكمبيوتر والادب
الانجليزي والاقتصاد والاثار والصناعات
النفطيه فسرت حكومه احمد نجاد الخطوه
بارتفاع اقبال النساء على اختصاصات لا
توفر لهن فرص عمل مرتفعه ما دع الى تنظيم
مختلف لتوزيعه على الشعب اكاديميه خاصه
وان ازيد من 60% من الملتحقين سنويا
بالجامعات الايرانيه من النساء في المقابل
لم تستبعد وجهات نظر اخرى ان يكون للامر
علاقه بتسجيل تراجع في نسب الزواج
والانجاب عزتها الحكومه الى ارتفاع
المستوى التعليمي للمراه الايرانيه انقسمت
الطبقه السياسيه حول القرار الحكومي
المثير للمواقف المتباينه حيث عارض
البرلمان الايراني القرار شكلا وقرر بناء
على ذ ذك استدعاء مساعد وزير التعليم
العالي في جلسه مسائله على خلفيه تجاوز
القرار لصلاحيات لجنه التعليم العالي في
البرلمان عدا عن ذلك عبرت الاوساط
الاكاديميه خاصه اساتذه الجامعات عن رفضها
للتوجه الجديد بالتزامن مع مواقف مماثله
صدرت عن شخصيات وجهات حقوقيه رات فيه
اجحافا مفضوحا بحق المراه مواقف عبرت عنها
الناشطه الحقوقيه الحائزه على جائزه نوبل
شيرين عبادي ومنظمه
التي حثت الحكومه الايرانيه على التراجع
عن قرارها ما بدا في مظهره قرارا اكاديميا
سرعان ما تحول الى حطب لتجاذب سياسيه
وحقوق داخليه سلطت الاضواء على حصاد حكومه
الرئيس احمدي نجاد والحكمه من سياساتها
تجاه المراه الايرانيه التي قيل ان
مولاتها عاده ما تجري خلاف ما تشتهيه سفن
اليمين المحافظ الحاكم في
ايران لمناقشه هذا الم ضوع معنا من طهران
الكاتب والباحث السياسي حسين رويان ومن
لندن الدكتور علي نوري زاده مدير مركز
الدراسات الايرانيه والعربيه ومن نيويورك
للنول مديره حقوق المراه في منظمه هيومان
رايتس وتش ونبدا مع السيد يوران من طهران
ونسال ما المبررات التي ساقتها الحكومه
الايرانيه لمثل هذا
القرار بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني اولا
هذا القرار محسوم لحد الان هو قرار يعني
مشروع اختباري يشمل 10% من الجامعات
الايرانيه فقط في الوقت الحالي القرار
لازال قيد التداول مجلس الشورى الايراني
او البرلمان لم يصادق عليه وزاره التعليم
العالي ايضا لم تصادق عليه يعني مجلس
اداره الجامعات بعض الجامعات هو الذي قرر
يعني هذه المساله المسوغات المطروحه حاليا
ان بعض الفروع كان اقبال احد الجنسين هو
اقل من 3% فتم حسم الامر لصالح الجنس
الاخر والمساله هي ليست حرمان المراه بل
اعاده هيكله للجامعات هناك فروع خصصت
للنساء مثل التمريض والامراض النسائيه
وهناك فروع خصصت ل الرجال مثل التعدين مثل
الزراعه
مثل الفيزياء النوويه وما الى ذلك من هنا
الحكومه تقول ان ما يجري هو اعاده هيكله
ولا زال قيد التداول اليوم في الصحف
المحليه كانت هناك ثلاث مقالات
ا يعني جلها ينتقد القرار ولا يؤيده على
الاعتبار انه الان يخلق حاله اي غير
طبيعيه يعني الان تم تنفيذ هذا القرار في
مثلا محافظه خوزستان البنات لا يستطيعون
الاناث يذهبون الى بعض الفروع في حين انه
في المحافظه المجاوره نفس هذه المساله
قائمه
لاناث للالتحاق بنفس هذه الفروع من هنا
هناك نعم نوع من الضبابيه في هذا القرار
تسود بعض الجامعات ا نتحول لضيفنا الثاني
من لندن الدكتور علي نوري زاده دكتور علي
اذا 10% فقط من الجامعات الايرانيه من
طالها او سيطالها بالاحرى هذا القرار الذي
لازال قيد النقاش الى حد الان وهو عباره
عن اعاده هيكله كما وصفه السيد رويان اذا
لماذا كل هذه الجلبه وهذا الضجيج
حوله تحياتي اليكم الى ضيوفكم والى
المشاهدين ال
اولا الوره لستما رسمها
السان
س جامعه من اهم الجامعات بها جامعه تهران
جامعه اصفهان جامعه صنعت جامعه سنا جامعه
امر كبر جامعه طباطبا رض الجامعات اان
قررت من النسا من اختار
س7 اختصاص واقول بعض هذا اساسات
التربيه
الكيميا اللغه والعد الانجليزي ترجمه
اللغه الانجليزيه العلوم الاقتصاديه
التاريخ جغرافيا العلوم السياسيه الحقوق
وحت هياه
السجاد وهذا دليل اخر على ان التمز الذي
يمارس بحق النساء في ايران هذا التمييز
بات اكثر تشددا و
بسبب ان اولا هذا واحد والثاني ايه الله
خامن سبق ان طالب الحكومه ب الغاء بعض
الاختصاصات في العلوم الانسانيه مثل
الفلسفه مثل الادب الفارسي الحديث او غير
ذلك حتى لا نخو بكل هذه الاختصاصات دكتور
علي الحكومه تقول بان رغبتها هي تنظيم سوق
العمل ليس اكثر من
ذلك ابدا ابدا هناك اولا بطاله ب الرجال
اثر من النساء معظم خلجات
الجامعات
سيجد مهاما في يعني لانه نساء مهتمين اكثر
بامل ساين اكثر من الرجال فلذلك سوق الامل
مفتوح امامهم ليس كل ذلك اولا النظام يرد
بمرور الزمن تحويل الجامعات الى حوزات
دينيه وهذا كان في فكر اي الله
خميني جامعه والوزه ووجود النساء مانع
ورادع وجود الفتيات الشابات في الجامعات
مانع مهم امام تحويل الجامد الى الوزه
فهذا هو اخر دليل هذه نقطه سنتحول بها
ونعود بها الى ضيفنا من طهران لكن قبل ذلك
دعنا ربما نسمع راي اخر من منظمه هيومان
رايتس وش التي اصدرت بيانا بهذا الخصوص
ونتحول السيده ليسل ونسال بيانكم دليل على
مخاوف على اي اساس بنيتم وهل الامر متعلق
لان من قام بهذا القرار واتخذه هي ايران
ام انكم كنتم ستتخذ ربما نفس اللهجه ونفس
النبره ايا كانت الدوله التي كانت اتخذت
مثل هذا
القرار نحن سنفعل هذا ازاء اي بلد يحاول
تقييد الحريات وما يثير قلقنا ان ايران
لديها تقاليد عريقه بتقديم فرص دراسيه
للرجال والنساء وكانت هناك اوقات حيث كان
طلبه
الجامعات تشكل النساء
60% بينهم اذا كانت هناك دائما نسبه عاليه
من
اناث يدرسن في الجامعات ونعلم ان هذا
القرار كان يعود الى قرار سابق لوزاره
التعليم العالي نشر في بيان في شهر اب
اغسطس الماضي وسوف يقلل من عدد المقاعد
الدراسيه للنساء وهذا سبب قلق وبعث قلق
قوي لكل منظمات حقوق الانسان وسيكون له
تاثير يت ناب عكسيا مع قدراتهن وخاصه في
مجال دراسات الفلسفه واللغات والتي تم
تقييدها للنساء فقط واذا الرجال سيحرمون
من ذلك في نفس الوقت نعود مره اخرى لدكتور
يوران ونعود اليه بما ذكره ضيفان السيده
ليسل تقول بان الغريب ان لايران تقاليد
عريقه بخصوص تقديم الفرص
للاناث تحديدا في سوق العمل لكن بالمقابل
دكتور علي يقول بان النظام الايراني الان
يريد تحويل الجامعات الايرانيه لحوزها
دينيه ونحن نسال سيد رويان اليس غريبا ان
يقدم النظام الايراني على مثل هذه الخطوه
رغم كل الضغوط والاعين المفتوحه عليه سواء
بخصوص ملفه النووي او حتى انتقادات فيما
يخص الموضوع
السوري يعني اولا كما ذكرت ان الموضوع
لازال قيد التداول و لكن مجرد طرح ايا ايا
كان ذلك هو طرح يعني موضوع للتداول لكن ان
مرر طبعا النظام الايراني سيكون معنيا بان
يصبح قرارا
نافذا هذا صحيح يعني اولا اريد ان اقول في
ايران 4 ملايين طالب جامعي وهذا يعكس
الاقبال الكبير ل الطلاب على تكميل
المرحله الجامعيه المساله الثانيه حوافز
النساء يعني المراه الايرانيه قويه
بطبعها وقويه في
حضورها هذا اقر به الجميع لكن لماذا الان
التغيير في الاستراتيجيه
هذه يعني هذا الموضوع كان مطروح منذ عده
سنوات و بعض الجامعات اخذت ب داخليه ولحد
الان ليس هناك من قرار وطني يشمل كل
الجامعات اي حدود حدود 75% من الجامعات في
ايران هي جامعات خاصه وتتبع قرارات
داخليه اضافه الى كل ذلك هناك بعض
المسوغات او يعني ال المشاكل الاجتماعيه
التي سمحت بطرح هذا الموضوع مثلا خلال
الخمس سنوات السابقه كان عدد الاناث في
الجامعات يزيد على 60% وفي السنه الماضيه
قار مضير مضير في ذلك ان كنا متفوقات على
الرجال نعم يعني اريد اذكر هذه المساله
بالتحديد يعني يعني عندما تكون المراه
يعني متعلمه جامعيا يجب ان تتزوج كفؤ لها
يكون بنفس المستوى الاجتماعي والدراسي
وهذا ما لا تجده بسبب ضعف الاقبال عند
الرجال وهذا ما وسع دائره العنوسه بين
النساء بشكل كبير جدا من هنا نعم هناك بعض
الدراسات الاجتماعيه التي تطرح يعني
تنفيذ تع به قد يدعو فعلا ل الاستهجان على
كل سنعود
للنقاش يعني حرمان المراه من التعليم
لمنحها فرصه في الزواج منطق ربما غريب وقد
يستهجن بعض المشاهدين على ك سنعود للنقاش
حول هذا الموضوع لكن بعد فاصل
[موسيقى]
قصير اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
نتحول مباشره الى ضيفنا من لندن الدكتور
علي ونسال يعني حتى باعتراف السيده ليس من
منظمه هيومان رايتس واتش قبل الفاصل بان
ايران لديها
ربما تقاليد عريقه في مجال تعليم البنات
او حتى فتح المجال للعمل لهن
وبالتالي لماذا الاتهامات هذه بالتضييق
على المراه وحتى بممارسه تمييز ضدها على
ما يمكن ان تستند ان كان هذا القرار في
نهايه الامر لم يتم الحسم فيه بعد وهو لا
يزال محل جدل
ونقاش دعن دعن سيدتي اوح لكم ان النساء
الايرانيات قد حسنا على حقوقهن الشرعيه في
الامس
63 اي قبل 15 عاما من قيام الثوره فلذلك
لما قامت الثوره ما فعله غاده الثوره كان
سحب حقوق النساء الايرانيات بشكل تدريجي
وانا والله اعتزوا واشادوا بنساء
الايرانيات التي
بمقاومته قد اجبرنا النظام الا تراجع بعض
قراراتها والا كان قرار الاول بمنع النصاب
من دخول الادارات والمؤسسات الحكوميه
وتولي كما فعلوا النساء الايرانيات قبل
الثوره كانوا كنا يتولي مقام قضاء يعني
كان هناك عديد من الغضه من النصب والسفراء
والوزراء والممثلات في البرلمان وبعد
الثوره النساء الايرانيات
بمقاومته قد تمكننا من حصول او ابقاء على
بعض حقوقهن الان في مساله
استاذ من تهران يقول بان هذا مشروع ابدا
نتائج امتحان امتحان هذا الام للجامعات
الايرانيه اؤت وبموجب هذا النتاائج
فان طالبات قد حرمنا من دخول
77 تخصص وهذا معناه ان القرار نف ولس
بانتظار مصادقه
البرلمان حت واضحين دتور عل هنك الان جدل
في طهران البرلمان لا يوافق دع لاستجواب
نائب وزير التعليم العالي لاعاده مناقشه
هذا
القرار انا اقول لكم بكل الصدق وخلوص ان
الغراق سوف ينفذ والنساء الايرانيات ننتظر
حتى نرى ردود الطيات ونساء وطالبات ولكن
الان اؤت النتاائج واولئك الذين كانوا
يريدون مثلا اختيار فرع هندسه وهندسه
البناء وهند واضح تماما واضح تماما د
نتحول للسيده ليسل من منظمه هيومان رايتس
واتش عذرا دكتور علي سيده ليسل سمعتي
لدفاع ضيفنا من طهران على قرار الحكومه
وما تحدث عنه من انه ربما فرصه لمنح
النساء المتعلمات خريجات الجامعه ربما
منعهن من الوصول الى مراحل متقدمه من
التعليم لمنح هن فرصا اكبر في الزواج كيف
ترون مثل هذه الدفاعات او مثل هذه
الدفوعات اعتقد ان هذه واحده من
اكثر الاسباب غرابه اسمعها وراء تبريرات
هذه مثل هذه القرارات لكنها لا تجيب على
سؤال اساسي وهو لماذا يتم تقييد حقوق
الدراسه الاكاديميه للرجال والنساء
بالنسبه للنساء هناك الكثير من المواد حرم
منها النساء وهناك ايضا بعض المواد حرم
منها الرجال بالنتيجه هل هذا له علاقه
باسلم التعليم العالي كما يقال منذ سنوات
لانه يبدو انه يستهدف النساء بشكل معين من
حيث الحصص وايضا بعض فر
الدراسه هذه التقييدات فرضت من قبل وانا
اتفق مع ضيفكم في لندن بان يبدو ان هذا
الامر يدفع
باتجاه فقط من جانب وزير التعليم العالي
والتكنولوجيا لكن ايضا ما تفيد به مصادرنا
في ايران وبعض وسائل الاعلام ان الكثير من
المقررات الدراسيه تم الغاؤها وسد ابواب
امام المراه في الدخول اليها سيد روران قد
يسال
يعني مشاهد ربما كيف بدوله تسعى فعلا لان
تتقدم في المجال النووي واكتساب الطاقه
النوويه ان تمنع نصف مجتمعها من تخصصات في
هذا المجال من تخصصات في الهندسه في
الترجمه الانجليزيه كيف يمكن ان تفهم هذه
الخطوه من هكذا
دوله يعني اولا هذا القرار كما اسلفت انه
ليس قرارا وطنيا يعني اليوم كان رئيس لجنه
التربيه والتعليم في مجلس الشورى الاسلامي
الدكتور
زاهدي دفع
بم
قبول السريع في هذا الاطار اليوم في صحيفه
شرق الايرانيه وزير التربيه السابق محمد
علي
نجفي هاجم ايضا هذا القرار هذا يعكس ماذا
يعكس ان القرار غير محسوم وان هناك اطراف
تدافع عن هذا القرار واطراف تهاجم هذا
القرار وهذا يعكس ان المساله غير محسومه
من هنا يعني هذا القرار انا لا اريد ان
ابرر
اي بقدر ما اريد ان اوضح الارضيه القائمه
هنا من يتصور ان حقوق المراه يعني يمكن ان
تنقظ في ايران بشكل كبير هو واهم بسبب
شخصيه المف من كلامك سيد روان انه ممكن ان
تتم مراجعه القرار وبالتالي التراجع
عنه نعم نعم هذا هو مطروح وبقوه يعني الان
يعني المراه في ايران قويه وموجوده في كل
المجالات يعني الان هناك نائبان لرئيس
الجمهوريه من النساء وزيره الصحه من
النساء
وهذا كله يعكس ان الحضور المراه في ايران
قوي جدا ولا شك انه سيبذل جهده لرفع هذا
التقييد
الذي يواجه فقط لضيق الوقت دعنا نتحول
للدكتور علي ونود ان نسال هنا مدام حسب
وجهه نظر السيد روران انه بالامكان العوده
او التراجع او حتى مراجعه هذا القرار هل
تملك المعارضه ايه اوراق قانونيه او حتى
سياسيه للضغط بهذا
الاتجاه
في العام الماضي انا اقول لكم في العام
الماضي منوا النساء من اربعه وخمسه تخصصات
وتم ذلك يعني بالفعل وهذا السنه ماذا عن
الالاف من الفضيات اللواتي طالبنا بانضمام
الى تخصصات 77 تخصص ووفقا لهذا القرار
الذي نفذ ماذا عنهن ماذا سيجري لهن فاعتقد
هذا القرار لا رجو لانه اييت الله خامن
كلف وزير التعليم العالي باسمه الجامعات
اولا بمن الفروق الموسيقي بمان فروق
الفلسفه
والفن والفن المعاصر والادب المعاصر وكل
ذلك والان اذا باعتقادك بان القرار نافذ
لا محال نتحول السيده ليس وسؤال اخير من
نيويورك سيده ليس انتم كمنظمه منظمه
هيومان رايتس واتش ماذا عساكم فعلا ان
تفعلوا في مثل هذه الحالات غير البيانات
بيانات التنديد والشجب بمثل هذه
الخطوات نحن بالتاكيد سوف نحث المجتمع
الدولي وايران ليقوم المجتمع الدولي
بالزام ايران بالايفاء بتعهداتها الدوليه
وبتطبيق
ضماناتها الدستوريه تجاه حقوق المراه
اعتقد ان هذا منبر مهم بالنسبه الينا وسوف
نحث المجتمع الدولي على طرح هذه الاسئله
والان الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في
حاله انعقاد سوف نحاول اثاره هذه القضيه
مع الوفد الايراني وهذا ما نستطيع عمله
بامكاننا ان نفضح هذه الممارسات وهذه
الانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان وان نشجع
المجتمع الدولي على الزام الحكومات
المعنيه بالايفاء بتعهدات شكرا جزيلا لليس
جت هول مديره حقوق الانسان حقوق المراه
عفوا في منظمه هيومان رايتس واتش كنت معنا
من نيويورك كما نشكر ضيفنا من لندن
الدكتور علي نوري زاده مدير مركز الدراسات
الايرانيه والعربيه ونشكر ضيفنا من طهران
الكاتب والباحث السياسي حسين رويان بهذا
مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عليكم
[موسيقى]
ل